Let's look at all the offers that I've ever had in my life.
We'll just go through the offers in tech because, um,
you guys probably don't care about the fact that I worked at McDonald's,
even though that MacDonald was a pretty
fine job, I don't want to brag,
but I was a top performing employee. Actually. That's not true.
I was the worst. And, uh, why? Because I didn't care.
I didn't really care about my job. I mean, McDonald's,
that's like a low tier company, you know,
a high chair company would be like in and out,
but I didn't get an offer from them. So,
You know,
it's the reason why I like wearing hats so much because it reminds me of the
good old times, the humble beginnings of Joel Matech.
Now let's go through the tech offers.
Now I want to explain that I went to university of Waterloo,
the best school in Canada. It's basically like MIT,
but for Canada in Waterloo,
we usually have to do five to six internships. One semester you at school,
one semester you do an internship. One semester, you at school,
one semester you had internship blah-blah-blah.
So the system in which we apply to jobs is called job mine apparently announced
called Waterloo works or something like that. But so in job mine,
they record all of your job application. Actually.
They only remember all of the ones that you had an interview for.
And then you could either have three things either. You're not ranked.
It means the company does not want you at all.
Or you are ranked because some companies,
they only hire maybe one intern for the season.
And then because they only hire one intern.
What they do is that they rank the interviewees. Okay.
So this is my first co-op job. I think I was in,
I was a freshmen, right? Uh, right after freshmen.
Usually your first co-op term, your first internship, it's pretty bad.
It's pretty bad. Um,
everyone in Canada or in Waterloo wants to go to Cali.
We have something called Kelly or bust.
It means you either go to California to get a job, or you bust,
meaning you just get nothing, which is kind of a risky move.
It means you just apply to all California jobs because that's, you know,
Silicon Valley. And then if you don't get any job, you're pretty.
All right. So let's check it out.
So this was my first ever co-op and here you go.
I had one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10, 11.
I had 11 interviews, uh, note that I,
I applied to 50 jobs because 50 was the maximum.
So I applied to 50 jobs and then I had one, two, three, four, five,
six, six ranked, or offer one, two, three, four.
I had four offer and two ranked.
Now let's look at the unranked one real quick.
Look at this Palentier.
I got Palentier interview for my first term,
which is crazy. Now. Usually they only hire seniors,
which is true because they didn't hire me. But then again,
I was extremely unqualified for it. You know, I just started coding.
I didn't know anything about software engineering,
but I got pretty far because I think what I did was, um,
they came to, to our school to talk about Palentier and stuff like that.
And then I started talking or chatting with one of the person.
He was a Ford deployed engineer. And apparently he was from Montreal too.
I was like, Oh, I'm from Montreal too. Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And then we bonded over that. And then he was able to get me an interview,
which is very rare, but yeah.
And then I passed the phone interview and they were quite impressed.
But then once I got to the onsite, it's not really an onsite.
They actually come to Waterloo to do the interview.
They asked me a systems question, I'll say, yeah, there's no way.
I know anything. Like, I didn't know anything about computers back then.
I didn't know anything about software engineering. So yeah.
I felt it easy peasy. Yeah.
So like the first jobs you usually get like QA positions or, you know,
positions.
And that that's exactly what I got as you see QA for bank of America.
And then I did not get quantitative research while that must be a really
hardcore job. Quantitative research macro Montreal, didn't get that.
Does art you learn, Oh,
that's actually a good first company to be at in Waterloo, but didn't get that.
Oh, but I got the QA version, the QA developer for it.
But I did not take that in the end. I took Scotiabank because,
uh, as analyst credit and equity derivatives,
that's actually a financial engineering position.
So I've had friends that went there and it's a pretty legit job.
My friends were seniors or juniors and they had this job.
So to get it as a freshmen, I was pretty proud.
So I took that job.
And then if we go to the second year as a sophomore,
as you can see, I got one, two, three, three offers, one ranked and then one,
two, three, four, five, five rejection out of all of these interviews.
So this one, I was actually pretty happy. I worked pretty hard for it.
And fortunately, I got a lot of these finance slash tech jobs.
So as you can see, I was still in finance. I got an offer from Bloomberg.
That was like the first offer I got.
And I was quite happy because Bloomberg for second co-op is pretty
legit. I think, because I want to go to America. I even told my advisor.
I said, I want to go to America.
But then my advisor told me, no, you shouldn't do that. That's,
that's a stupid decision to make. You're not going to get it. Honestly,
that guy. If I listened to him, I probably wouldn't have been, you know,
working at these nice companies nowadays. But yeah, he literally said,
don't even think about it. That is so disrespectful.
So what I did was I applied to only American jobs.
So it's kind of like Cali or bus, but instead it's America or bust.
And look at that, I got three offers from us.
Oh actually,
actually it's more than just three offer actually got quantitative brokers too.
But the thing about employers is sometimes they call you, they say, Oh,
do you want this offer? If not, then I'm not going to,
I'm not going to rank you.
I'm not going to offer you because it's kind of like a game theory thing or a
matching problem. But, you know,
I got cooler job offers like Citadel investment. That was a big deal.
I actually have a video that talks about, um, Citadel. So yeah. Check,
check that out if you want. Oh yeah. By the way,
at this point I started knowing how to crack the interview. I mean,
I'm not going to talk about how exactly like what I did to get the offers
because I already made videos of that. And I'll also,
I have a whole course on it called tech interview pro.com, uh,
which is really good. Uh, I mean,
you should check it out now because there's a 50% off currently for labor day
week. Um, it's,
it's pretty much a video course that teaches you exactly how to ACE an
interview.
And there's like a private Facebook group where we answer questions and there's
like live Q and a where we host like every two weeks. So yeah,
definitely check it out. If you're preparing to interview, it's really good.
I'm super proud of this course. And uh, yeah. Cool.
I hope that you guys would enjoy it too, but yeah. Check it out.
This is my third co-op and now I, you know, I got the hang of it, but uh,
I want it to go into pure software companies, right? Like LinkedIn, Facebook,
Google, those kinds of things. So I didn't want to do finance tech anymore.
So now this time I applied to my dream companies.
So as you can see the offers, I got, I got Coursera. Coursera was good.
I, I liked the interview. The interview was pretty good. Uh, as you can see, I,
uh, I got rejected by Google. You know,
my dream company got rejected and then LinkedIn, I got an offer there,
which was great. I made a video about it on how I got an internship at LinkedIn.
You could, should check that out. And then Microsoft for embedded systems,
I did not get it, but I got the software development, engineering role.
That makes sense. I didn't know anything about embedded systems.
I had no idea how I got the interview. I thought I did decently well, but,
but yeah, probably not. Cause cause they rejected me once again,
applied to Palentier technologies, but I didn't get it this time. I was right.
Yeah. She asked me the same question, but I still failed.
And then Tinder, yo,
this was the first time they were hiring interns from Waterloo and I got the
offer. They only picked one. I remember because, um, I did the interview.
I even talked to the CTO. Wait, what happened? Oh yeah.
Remember like I had a porn Dora. Yeah. So I made porn Dora,
but um, I like, I, I didn't list it here exactly on my resume.
Cause we did I LinkedIn corporate actually. Yeah, I did. I did.
I think I did put in my porn Dora, um,
project,
but I called it like video streaming site or something like that.
But yeah, because I did that project, I learned a lot about AWS, you know?
So anything with like auto-scaling stuff, you know,
using S3 CDNs and stuff like that because it was very like video intensive kind
of things.
So I think I really impressed the CTO because I knew a lot of these scrappy
technologies that you usually use when you build a project from scratch.
So I, uh, yeah, I think the CTO liked me, so that was great.
And then also the recruiter was super cute, but.
Um.
Yeah. I don't know if she imagined she watches my videos. That'd be great.
Uh, should I message her nostril.
Anyways? And then I also got the Yelp offer. That was pretty cool. Yext.
I have no idea what Yext is.
So that's pretty much it for the co-op because after that I actually dropped out
of co-op. The reason is because I didn't want to do PD,
which is the professional development.
You had to write an essay about the work that you've done or something like
that. And I really, really didn't want to do it.
So I just dropped out of the whole co-op system and I just found jobs myself.
I went to Facebook and then after that I went to Microsoft,
I went to Facebook for data science and Microsoft for uh, product management,
program management. And um, yeah, I just got a referral didn't interview and,
you know, got the offer.
I didn't really take the chance to interview a bunch of places,
which I do regret for full time when I got out of, um,
school. I think I applied to a lot of different companies too.
I got rejected from Palentier again. Uh, yeah.
I was just never able to go to Palentier.
I got rejected by Facebook RPM for product management.
I got rejected by Google APM. Uh, so it's a program, uh,
associate product manager. Yeah. So, uh, that's pretty much it.
And then the offers I got was like Buzzfeed for data science,
cause I want to get famous. And then I went there. Um,
I already had a return offer for Facebook. I had a return offer from Microsoft.
I ended up going to, um, what's it called again? Yeah. Buzzfeed.
And then, I mean,
I did get a few offers for my recent switch from data science to
software. So the offers that I got were, Oh,
sorry about that. The camera,
the camera was doing something where I guess it got cut off. Yeah.
Anyways. So.
That's about it. Um, now to the quick updates,
I just want to thank each and every one of you who donate it to the fundraiser,
to my fundraiser for mental health America. And uh, yeah, in case you forgot,
uh, I was giving out these corgis for everyone who donated and we
passed our goal. The goal was $2,000 and we passed it and uh,
I still have a lot of corgis left,
so I'm just gonna increase the goal to $3,000 now. But uh, yeah,
I'm super happy about it. The turnout was super great.
And you guys are doing this for a great cause.
So thank you so much for donating. So I rarely talk about my personal life, but
um, I guess I'll tell you this. I actually have a roommate. Uh,
she is a high school teacher teaching environmental science.
I have massive respect for her. She's doing something great.
She's teaching something very important and she teaches me all the time too.
I'm basically a man-child and she helps me become less of a
man-child. So I really, really appreciate her today.
I wanted to surprise her by giving her a new Mac book
pro provided by brilliant.org. Thank you so much for sending that. So thanks.
brilliant.org for sponsoring this video and sending this MacBook pro for her and
a brilliant.org in case you don't know,
it is a website that publishes daily challenge everyday on STEM.
The site is extremely sleek and they have over 50 interactive courses,
which makes learning these concepts so much easier.
I actually use them when I prep for my data science interviews,
because their probability section was really, really good.
This website is a great compliment to universities because you get to
practice all these things that you've learned in theory in class.
And then you can finally apply it to these questions. For example, me myself,
I'm more of a doer than a listener. I have to try after practice.
I have to do things and I wish that I had brilliant.org when I was in school
because I would be able to practice my questions.
I would able to apply my knowledge to see if I actually understand.
So if you're interested, don't forget to go on brilliant.org/joma.
And the first 200 people will get 20% off, all right.
Back to my roommate. So I asked her to talk about, um, water bottle usages.
And, um, I, there was basically an excuse to film it, to film her reaction.
But I mean, the thing that she says is really important.
So you should listen to it, but this is what happened for the short break.
I want to talk to you about something quite important and it's about water
balls.
Now I have my roommate here and she's going to be talking about something really
important.
So I'm about water bottles, right? Okay. So, well,
chances are you drank out of water bottles, um, you know,
some time in your life and more likely than not,
it's probably a plastic water bottle. Um,
and unfortunately that's probably not the best thing to do for our environment,
of course, because we all live on this planet and we share it.
And plastic is made out of oil,
which is a fossil field that unfortunately we don't have very
much of left in our world and we, you know,
don't want to run out of it and we have a lot of other applications for it.
Okay. So plastic water bottles, you know,
it doesn't always end up where you think it might when you're done using it.
So what is easy trick.
To prevent this issue?
Um, it probably be a good idea to get a reusable water bottle. Oh.
Nice.
So it's really important, which is why I have my own water bottle.
So as you can see using, we use of a water bottle is very, very important.
That's why I always use a reusable water bottle.
Wait, this was plastic bottle. Oh yeah. That's dumb.
I didn't, it didn't realize that.
Thank you for doing this video. So I have a little surprise for you.
Close your eyes. It's a little gift for you.
All right. You can open your eyes. This is yours.
This is sponsored by.
Thank you so much for providing this MacBook pro,
which I give to my roommate because she's a great teacher.
It's yours. It's not,
it's not just for, I was hoping for a better one.
[Inaudible].
Yeah, this is a, this is yours for all your hard work. Why?
All the good con I'm really confused right now. I mean, brilliant Santos.
A laptop. So since I have already three of them, I don't need them.
I don't know what to do.
That's okay.
Okay. Here's how you're supposed to react.
No way. No, no, no, no. I can't accept no way.
Oh my God.
That's what you, that's what you were supposed to do. So let's do that again.